avec 34 1514 emploi les yvelines sont
classés numéro un français en terme
d'effectif salarié dans le secteur de
l'automobile
si le département est devenu un lieu
historique de production de véhicules en
ile de france c'est grâce au passage de
la seine en amont de paris ainsi que sa
proximité avec la capitale
les produits pouvant être transportés
plus facilement par bateau 20e siècle
quatre communes concentre aujourd'hui la
quasi totalité des salariés de la
filière le technocentre renault de
guyancourt et le principal pôle
yvelinois onze mille salariés
travaillent pour la recherche et le
développement des futures voitures de la
marque
c'est le plus grand centre de recherche
de france il permet à l'entreprise
d'éviter de nombreux coups en frais de
déplacement autres citronnelle usine
située à flins aubergenville et le 4e
employeur événement site historique de
la renault clio
il fabrique actuellement les renault zoé
ainsi que les nissan micra
il ne produira plus prochainement
d'automobiles parmi les autres pôles on
trouve deux centres psa l'un situé à
vélizy villacoublay destinées en partie
à conceptualiser le design des futurs
modèles
le second à poissy spécialisée dans la
motorisation des véhicules
ces deux espaces regroupe au total neuf
mille six cents salariés
les sièges de firmes étrangères se sont
également installés progressivement dans
le département en particulier à saint
quentin en yvelines
on retrouve ainsi les sièges mercedes
benz bmw france est nissan europe à
montigny le bretonneux ou encore fiat
france à trappes
en tout ce sont 350 établissements
rassemblés dans les yvelines soit 23% du
total en ile de france